[Music]
busiest man in Nashville right now I
gotta say I feel like it I really do
yeah no rest for you you look great
though you don't look tired and I think
with an infidel that's a big compliment
I appreciate that right off the bat how
is life with two little ones at home
right now
it's pretty intense because I kind of
feel like when one of them goes to sleep
the other one wakes up and vice versa
and but we're just we're figuring out as
we go and and it's been it's been a fun
journey thus far house more and I saw
her today she looks like a rock star
yeah I mean she's doing amazing besides
being you know a little bit
sleep-deprived like we both are we're
both doing pretty good considering the
circumstances and so we're just you know
we're excited to kind of start to learn
how to be better better and better
parents everyday and and you know get
the kiddos out on the road yeah I can't
ask you this earlier today about playing
your music for the little ones were you
playing ADA anything in the womb yeah I
mean anything we were listening to I'm
in were playing a ton of stuff to
Laurens stomach just because my dad used
to told me he played me the Rolling
Stones and Led Zeppelin's on my mom's
stomach before I was born so I'm
convinced that they hear that stuff and
they come out and when they you know
maybe later when they're 13 or 14 they
hear it they kind of feel something
because I might have heard in the past
oh your dad was a country star and you
followed in his footsteps what would you
do if your girls came to you and said
they wanted to be country music stars I
would persuade them probably not to do
it yeah my dad told me the same thing
it's just it is a it's a tough business
for sure and it's very competitive and
takes a lot of your time but at the same
time I can't really imagine myself to
anything different so if they were that
passionate about our beat super
supportive
[Music]